I don't I don't was decide on any anyone
so it's lunchtime in New York City and I
just found out the world's hottest curry
is sold just down the street from
BuzzFeed's New York office
it's made with the Carolina Reaper
pepper which according to the Guinness
Book of World Records is the world's
hottest pepper it's rated at 2.2 million
on the Scoville scale so it's ten
thousand times hotter than a bottle of
Tabasco sauce the chef literally has to
wear a gas mask when he prepares it and
I figured if I'm gonna be eating the
world's hottest curry I gotta bring a
friend
[Applause]
they say that this challenge is
attempted anywhere between like 25 to 30
times every week okay generally only two
people aren't able to complete it
increase our chances
Rob and I will each have a quart of milk
in addition we will have some some Greek
yogurt you know you want to throw up
right from the house is great
good if you start hallucinating I like
eating spicy food I like curry I I don't
I think this is gonna be terrible
yeah I'm not sure how I feel about this
I have a few this is the last time we
ran out it's very possible like the last
meal
[Music]
it's a beautiful setup
yeah you shake it don't you agree
even the whole name
I mean is double some heat on that it's
growing
and it's growing uh I'm already starting
to sweat that's a lot of heat Wow
nobody hears you're itchy is that a
thing I'm starting to realize that this
was a stupid idea I told you that a week
ago
can't be worse than for it first peace
cannot be can't be worse
all right it's still gold but seven
pieces and worse than authorities how's
your meal
oh it's delightful
[Music]
there's no escaping it this is Christian
you have serious serious issues this is
a lot to just the two and a half million
scovilles to point you to point to
yeah that's not true half I would you so
true
Thanks this is not fun it's not cute
tears oh yeah to bleep that out no what
was two bites
did it get more cold in here all of a
sudden I don't think so that's not a
good Nizar do you take your coat off
though but that's that was a while ago
do you know what things would be worse
what your this is all the stuff that is
around the lamp like look at that this
is this is very powerful people out
there do the same that spicy oh you can
do that come and try it
come and try give us a call we'll come
and watch I can't believe you
is it gotten easier no this is and I
don't really hard he's really hard uh
this is uh that is evil right there as
not as good as I've been doing I'm
barely touching this that's the khari
all right I'm gonna go for this little
guy here
I don't know why I would do this to
myself all over again but we have all
the accoutrements to get us through it
oh here it comes so I have two pieces
left I am going to eat this and we'll
quickly eat the second one and then I
will I will discuss touching the curry
this is just the curry and like this is
more food that I've eaten yet there's
there's definitely some things happening
down here I gotta go to the bathroom
I'll be right back
do ya you just go to a one-shot a
Christian he's gonna finish all that
I'll be back in two seconds it's not an
emergency so let's see what I can with
damage I could do to this bowl if I just
keep on taking small little scoops
[Music]
that's yeah I just hate huh
nothing I ate before compares to what I
just did
oh no really haha okay but you're almost
there that's four bytes that was painful
I could see it the problem that I have
continued at the moment it's not that I
can't finish it because I could I have
the time to finish it I could it
requires so much yogurt and milk for
every bite you take
I don't have room full of yogurt okay
oh you know a room for it look if I had
more of this I couldn't continue to go
down that's still a lot that's a lot of
milk every trick in addition to the food
that was just like any any ambulance
calls oh yeah I mean there's one girl
she comes
why would you do that with a stomach
ulcer
so feel better I feel like I'm feeling
feeling like legit dizzy
really maybe you should go sit down
you're a big tree to fall man I catch
you
his ruff was your idea it was like
pictures swallowing a balloon of napalm
and then it bursts inside your belly
fast forward to later that night
whoa we can honestly say the burning I
experienced with the food going in is
matched by the burning of the food going
out why would anybody eat anything that
hot I mean it's ridiculous there's
absolutely no flavor it says right on
the menu that this is more pain and
sweat than there is flavor I didn't feel
good until about 30 hours after eating
the meal I would love to come back that
restaurants actually a really nice place
and have like you know normal food their
curries I'm sure are amazing that one
there though no that was ridiculous
BuzzFeed lent Rob out video I'll do more
videos yeah just know none of this [ __ ]